HELLO, I'M JAKE TAPPER IN
WASHINGTON WHERE THE STATE OF
OUR UNION IS WATCHING ECONOMIC
ANXIETY GROW.
PRESIDENT BIDE LISTEN CELEBRATE
A VICTORY TOMORROW, SIGNING THE
NEW BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL INTO LAW, BUT AS THE
PRESIDENT HERALDS THIS
PLESHMENT, ONE THAT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF AMERICAN
PEOPLE SUPPORT HE'S BEEN RUNNING
INTO ECONOMIC REALITY ACCORDING
TO DATA FROM THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS.
AS THE HOLIDAYS APROCHE,
AMERICANS ARE SEEING HIGHER
PRICES ON EVERYTHING FROM GAS TO
GROCERIES.
THIS WEEK, THE PRESIDENT CHANGED
HIS MESSAGE ON THE ISSUE
ACKNOWLEDGING FOR THE FIRST TIME
IT IS WORRISOME AND ONE OF THE
MOST PRESSING ECONOMIC CONCERNS
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE A
RESPONSE TO THE POLITICAL
REALITY A POLL FROM "THE
WASHINGTON POST"/ABC NEWS SHOWS
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING SINKING
TO 41%, A NEW LOW LARGELY
BECAUSE OF A NEGATIVE SHIFT
AMONG DEMOCRATS AND
INDEPENDENTS, AS 70% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ACCORDING TO
THIS POLL RATE THE ECONOMY
NEGATIVELY, 70%.
63% OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK
BIDEN HAS NOT ACCOMPLISHED MUCH
SO FAR.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS, BRIAN
DEESE.
LET'S START ON THIS DIRE
INFLATION REPORT.
LOOK AT HOW MUCH PRICES HAVE
RISEN, REGULAR GAS PRICES UP
MORE THAN 50%, UTILITY GAS 28%,
USED CARS, BEEF, PORK, EGGS ALL
UP, "THE WASHINGTON POST" POLL
SHOWS 70% OF THOSE POLLED VIEWED
THE ECONOMY NEGATIVELY.
38% SAY THE ECONOMY IS IN POOR
CONDITION.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT
INFLATION AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING
SPECIFICALLY TO FIX IT?
>> WELL, INFLATION IS HIGH RIGHT
NOW AND IT IS AFFECTING
CONSUMERS IN THEIR POCKETBOOK
AND ALSO IN THEIR OUTLOOK FOR
THE ECONOMY BUT THOSE CONCERNS
UNDERSCORE WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD ON THE
BUILD BACK BETTER LEGISLATION,
THIS LEGISLATION THAT THE HOUSE
IS GOING TO CONSIDER THIS WEEK.
THIS GOES AT THE COST AMERICANS
FACE.
THIS WILL LOWER PRESCRIPTION
DRUG PRICES, PUT A CAP ON
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS FOR OUR
SENIORS, CHILD CARE, NOT ONLY A
BIG COST DRIVER FOR FAMILIES BUT
BIG IMPEDIMENT FOR PARENTS AND
WOMEN TO GET BACK INTO THE
WORKFORCE.
THIS BILL WILL CUT THE COST OF
CHILD CARE BY MORE THAN HALF AND
HOUSING, THIS WILL BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOMES AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
FAMILIES TO AFFORD HOUSING AND
ALSO TO MOVE TO PLACES WHERE THE
JOB OPPORTUNITIES ARE.
ALL OF THESE THINGS GO AT
LOWERING COSTS FOR AMERICAN
FAMILIES AND THE BILL IS FULLY
PAID FOR.
IT'S NOT GOING TO ADD TO
INFLATIONARY PRESSURES.
QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
WE'LL PAY FOR EVERYTHING IN THIS
BILL RAISING TAXES ON BIG
COMPANIES, LARGE CORPORATIONS
AND HIGHEST INCOME AMERICANS.
THERE'S AN URGENCY TO ACT.
>> NOTHING YOU JUST MENTIONED
ASSUMING THAT EVERYTHING YOU'RE
SAYING IT ACCURATE AND COMES TO
PASS THE WAY YOU WANT, NOTHING
YOU MENTIONED WOULD BRING DOWN
GROCERY PRICES, BRING DOWN GAS
PRICES.
TAKE GAS PRICES FOR A SECOND.
IS PRESIDENT BIDEN WILLING TO
OPEN THE STRATEGIC PETROLEUM
RESERVE, WILLING TO STOP GAS AND
OIL EXPORTS TO ALEVE NATE THE
GAS PRICE ISSUE AT THE PUMP?
>> WE ARE VERY COMMITTED TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT AMERICANS CONSUMERS
DON'T BEAR THE BROUNT OF HIGH
GAS PRICES AND VALUE TILE ENERGY
PRICES.
ALL OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE,
WE'RE MONITORING THE SITUATION
CAREFULLY.
WE'RE FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
AMERICAN CONSUMERS DON'T GET
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
IN OIL AND GAS MARKETS BECAUSE
OF CONSOLIDATION WE HAVE FEWER
LARGE COMPANIES CONTROLLING THE
MARKET AND SO AT MOMENTS LIKE
THIS, THERE'S A REAL CONCERN OF
PRICE GOUGING OR MARKET MA NIP
PLACE THAT COULD PUT CONSUMERS,
COULD HARM CONSUMERS.
WE'VE ASKED THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMISSION TO LOOK AT THAT AND
THE MARKET CONDITIONS AND
ENGAGING INTERNATIONALLY WITH
COUNTERPARTS TO MAKE SURE OTHER
OIL PRODUCING NATIONS ARE NOT
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE VENG OF
THE RECOVERY AND ACTUALLY
PROFITING AT THE AMERICAN
CONSUMER'S EXPENSE.
WE'RE MONITORING IT CLOSELY AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
>> YOU SAW THE BAD POLL NUMBERS
FOR THE PRESIDENT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ECONOMY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH OF A
FACTOR THIS WAS BUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGED
INFLATION IS WORRISOME THIS
WEEK.
I WANT TO PLAY SOUND OF WHAT YOU
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN WERE SAYING
A FEW MONTHS AGO IN JUNE.
>> BY THE WAY, TALK OF
INFLATION, THE OVERWHELMING
CONSENSUS IT'S GOING TO POP UP A
LITTLE BIT AND THEN GO BACK
DOWN.
NO ONE'S TALKING ABOUT IS GREAT,
GREAT, YOU KNOW.
>> SO THE DEGREE PEOPLE ARE
FOCUSED ON INFLATIONARY
PRESSURES IN THE SHORT TERM THAT
IS NOT THE ISSUE.
>> DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
WRONG AND IT'S NOT A SHORT TERM
IT WILL POP UP AND GO BACK DOWN
ISSUE?
>> NO, I THINK WHAT WE'VE SAID
CONSISTENTLY THE PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMY ARE INTERLINKED AND
CERTAINLY WE SAW JUST AS THE
DELTA VARIANT POSED REAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES TO THE ECONOMY, I ADD
ECONOMIC IMPACTS, MORE PEOPLE
WERE CONSUMING GOODS AT HOME,
WATCHING TV RATHER THAN BUYING A
NEW TELEVISION, RATHER THAN
GOING OUT TO THE MOVIES AND
SPENDING ON SERVICES SO THAT'S
ADDED TO SOME OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN CHALLENGES WE FACE.
WE'RE SEEING THESE PRICE
INCREASES IN INFLATION GLOBALLY
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
COVID.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING AT
ATTACKING THOSE ISSUES RIGHT NOW
AS WELL.
IN THE VERY IMMEDIATE TERM WE'RE
WORKING WITH PORTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO GET GOODS MOVING MORE
QUICKLY THROUGH THE ECONOMY AND
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THE
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILL SIGN TOMORROW IS
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT STEP THAT
WE WILL HAVE TAKEN IN DECADES TO
ACTUALLY INVEST IN THE ARTERIES
THAT HELP MOVE GOODS MORE
QUICKLY THROUGH OUR ECONOMY,
MORE CHEAPLY THROUGH OUR ECONOMY
AND WAS DESIGNED SO WE CAN MOVE
OUT QUICKLY ON SOME AREAS LIKE
OUR PORTS TO TRY TO START
PROVIDING SOME RELIEF.
SO WE ARE, HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON
THIS ISSUE, WE CONTINUE TO BE
FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE IN THE
SHORT TERM AND ADDRESSING MEDIUM
TERM ISSUES AS WELL.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE BUILD BACK
BETTER ACT WHICH IS $1.75
TRILLION AS A SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM BUT YOUR PREDECESSOR
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA, LARRY
SUMMERS, HE POINTED THIS WEEK TO
THE $1.9 TRILLION RESCUE PLAN
PASSED EARL WHIER IN MARCH,
THAT'S A MAJOR REASON BEHIND THE
RISE IN INFLATION, SOMETHING HE
CALLED AT THE TIME "THE LEAST
RESPONSIBLE MACRO ECONOMIC
POLICY WE'VE HAD IN THE LAST 40
YEARS."
IS IT POSSIBLE AMERICANS ARE
SUFFERING FROM HIGH PRICES
BECAUSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OVERSTIMULATED THE ECONOMY WITH
ALL OF THIS MONEY GOING INTO THE
ECONOMY?
>> NO, THAT'S NOT OUR
PERSPECTIVE.
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN SAVED
US FROM AN ACUTE ECONOMIC
EMERGENCY.
IT'S HARD TO REMEMBER BUT RECALL
WHEN THE PRESIDENT TOOK OFFICE
THERE WERE 18 MILLION PEOPLE
COLLECTING UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
AND 3,000 AMERICANS A DAY DYING
BUT PROFESSOR SUMMERS AGREES ON
THE BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN THAT
IT WILL NOT INCREASE INFLATION
AND MAKING INVESTMENTS IN THINGS
LIKE LOWERING THE COST OF CHILD
CARE OR PROVIDING UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL WILL ACTUALLY IMPROVE
THE PRODUCTIVE CAPACITY OF OUR
ECONOMY.
SO I THINK WE ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT
WE NEED TO DO HERE.
WE NEED TO MAKE A FULLY PAID FOR
INVESTMENT THAT WILL ACTUALLY
UNLOCK MORE OPPORTUNITY, GET
MORE PEOPLE WORKING IN THE
ECONOMY AND THAT'S WHERE OUR
FOCUS IS.
>> IF YOU ARE STANDING BY YOUR
STATEMENT AND THE PRESIDENT'S
STATEMENT THAT INFLATION IS
TRANSITORY SHORT-LIVED, WHEN DO
YOU THINK INFLATION IS GOING TO
GO BACK BELOW THE 2% LEVEL
CONSIDERED NORMAL?
>> THERE'S LOTS OF INDEPENDENT
EXPERTS WHO PREDICT INFLATION.
I THINK CONSISTENT WITH WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT BEFORE,
AMERICANS ARE LESS INTERESTED IN
PREDICTIONS AND MORE INTERESTED
IN CONCRETE ACTION TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
THAT'S WHAT OUR FOCUS IS AND THE
POLL THAT YOU PUT FORWARD SHOWED
THAT A SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS SUPPORT THE COMPONENTS
OF THE BUILD BACK BETTER AGENDA
BECAUSE IT IS ORIENTED TOWARD
DELIVERING ON THE PRACTICAL COST
ISSUES THAT THEY FACE IN THEIR
LIVES, HOUSING, HEALTH CARE,
CHILD CARE, TRANSPORTATION.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT TYPICAL
AMERICANS ARE DEALING WITH AND
SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
AND ACTION IS GOING TO SPEAK
LOUDER THAN WORDS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING FOR AND WHY WE ARE
FOCUSED ON MOVING THIS BILL
THROUGH CONGRESS AND GETTING
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
IMPLEMENTED WITHOUT DELAY.
>> IS BUILD BACK BETTER GOING TO
PASS THE HOUSE THIS WEEK?
>> WELL, WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
IT WILL.
WE ARE CONFIDENT SPEAKER PELOSI
WILL BRING IT UP AND IT WILL
PASS THIS WEEK.
WE'LL MOVE FORWARD IN THE NEXT
PROCESS IN MOVING IT TO THE
SENATE.
>> IS THE S.A.L.T. TAX
DEDUCTION, STATE AND LOCAL TAX
DEDUCTION IN THE BUILD BACK
BETTER ACT?
SOME EXPERTS SAY IT COULD RESULT
IN THE WEALTHIEST AMERICANS IN
THE STATES GETTING A TAX BREAK.
>> WELL THERE'S A FIX TO THAT
ISSUE THAT IS INCLUDED IN THE
HOUSE BILL.
THIS WAS AN ISSUE THAT THE TRUMP
TAX CUT, THE 2017 TAX CUT
CREATED HUGE UNCERTAINTY IN OUR
TAX SYSTEM BY CAPPING THAT
DEDUCTION FOR STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS AND
LETTING THE CAP GO AWAY
COMPLETELY.
WHAT THE FIX IN THE HOUSE BILL
WOULD DO, PROVIDE A LONG-TERM
HIGHER CAP ON THAT ISSUE AND SO
THAT'S IN THE BILL AND